tout le monde sait ce quiz et aux jeunes
gens se retrouvent de nouveau sur the
grudge pour finir ce [ __ ] niveau de
l'hôpital de vin ou pas devin on va dans
la chambre 320 de manière immédiate bas
les steaks à aulaqi droite qui grognent
ya personne n'ose capital et peu de gens
cas ils grognent quoi mais c'est que ce
délire up la hâte en boîte
tu sais que ça recule recule recule ça
ça sent pas bon ça sent pas bon ça sent
ok il voulait faire eye-fi forcé mais je
vais bien avant la bon il a mal pris
c'est pas grave alors s'est passé je
chante 305 306 ok il me faut des
batteries la y avait des batteries peine
[ __ ] batterie et dans un placard
intrus n'ont pas perdu tant d'années oui
je laisse mon gars au attend le betty
caron face à traire le le meuble qu il
ya un gros problème
alors ok cinématiques une télé qui
s'allument hockey amh c'est l'ascenseur
de l'histoire qu'on a fait juste avant
ça marche ça c'est des gens nus qui font
la fête
les 305 parfait au salut shar haut qui
tape le chat ça fera un ami de plus on
sera plus serein
ah non mais dis pas qu'il faut ouvrir le
rideau attention panique panique ou
hockey à dow elle est au rideau vert au
mois tu veux pas faire peur mais que tu
mets pas fait peur pour rg fleuve c'est
un homme et sans déconner c'est quoi ça
j'ai eu un truc un papier griffonné ok
c'est vrai que c'est le meilleur truc
qui tu peux ramasser dans le jeu quoi
l'objet qui tu aideras dans ta tête tu
aideras un bac la femme au point la
jambe ou alors tu peux mettre à la
poubelle voilà c'est un bout de papier
téléphone sonne c'est pas la cc lacq a
fait bonjour oui à fond pour y tourner
carrément oh oui mais pour mon gars qui
s elle répond et dis moi que c'est maman
qui m'appellent pour me dire tu vas tu
as les trois sets 4 heures
ou un papier griffonné au pro le oui oui
oui je suis fait que ce qu'il fait mais
c'est pas ma [ __ ] bordel mais tu
restes un bon gars a du coup les pieds
puis j'ai vu quelqu'un c'est bon c'est
bon pour un papier ya quelqu'un là
quelqu'un il ya quelqu'un y arriver une
[ __ ] nom d un mois ou alors c'est
l'ombre du tabouret jeu le papier
non mais ça va aller cinématiques c'est
beau les ces mots aux toilettes des
hommes bah oui là où il ya la femme qui
sort et qui va faire semblant nous
défoncer et alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
oui c'est très bien oh non bottes met à
tomber
mais qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi ce chat
schizophrène quoi sans déconner papier
griffonné mais c'est génial
alors [ __ ] encore mais ça va un [ __ ]
et nous guider nous guident alors il
faut qu'on se casse par la non mais ça
va pas se passer comme ça il ya des bugs
attend le méchant est en transe
qu'est-ce qui au nom moga ok je suis
prêt pour la bataille droite à gauche
[Musique]
mais c'est une blague mais j'ai fait ce
qu'il fallait mais j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait mais ces scandales
mais non mais attends non mais sans
déconner mais je vais finir comme cette
pauvre femme sur la boîte du jeu et ça
continue tu croyais face du monde au
plat allez merci merci à tous alors il
faille vous pas vos plats dans l'ue sont
à la peine ce temps faites lui
l'habitude savez quoi à chaque fois
c'est un premier pas et la tension
l'arrivée ça moi je venais d'arriver
ok je suis prêt alors moi tu droite mais
se retrouve tout de suite pour défoncer
une bonne fois pour toutes cette [ __ ]
de femelles ac oui c'est moi c'est la
chanson qui donne le plus de courage aux
mots je suis prêt à vaincre ce démon
venue de ddd de des larmes
ok ce parti est cette fois ci je meurs
vraiment je pète un câble à la flèche
droite droite
ok c'est bon gauche gauche ces mots
gauche droite gauche droite ou je sais
pas ou pas c'est çà et là
en bas ça marchait olympique pitié pitié
si un autre je suis prêt à chaque
affrontement là un bon dieu à sa sortie
de ce qu on fait quoi faut monter ou
descendre
je pense qu'il faut que je descende non
on va descendre wow oh il ya un petit
kacou rue donc je pense qu'il faut
descendre
ouais c'est ça ben logiquement qu'on
parle d'un hôpital on va au rez de
chaussée à on se jette par la fenêtre
d'un étage
le rez-de-chaussée ça aux [ __ ] il ya
un vieux bruit à il a pris les devants
mais il est trop fort aussi court aux
côtés de schengen quoi ce petit garçon
nu il ya aucun homme sur la planète et
plus riches que nous en piles aa je
tiens à préciser où
c'est quoi ça mais il y en a partout oui
à bord et suivent les cheveux je pense à
ça c'est peut-être une idée de merde
j'en sais rien mais non mais attends
elle a tout pris d'assaut mais détente
ap jeune femme
ok on est bien yes on va devoir
l'affronter à tous les combats doit
l'affronter
on est prêts on est prêt fauve et ça
c'est verrouillé non tête par le kof ah
bah voilà quelque chose d'utile
c'est la clé de quoi les du toit mais
c'est une [ __ ] de blague faut qu'on
remonte tout là-haut comme s'ils avaient
le cocktail vient me chercher quoi
direction la gauche salue
la chute et micro ça va les steaks dont
à trois doigts
j'ai pas envie de recommencer j'apprends
vite recommencé japon au maroc c'est lui
le marsupilami start remise en place du
micro vous fait rire ça gens qui ont
peur comme ça
alors la prochaine vidéo ce sera sur
adibou voilà pas défaut dan adibou le
vrai a dit oui le gros problème ce mec
mais [ __ ] mais piqué le lâcher le
vétérinaire j'en sais rien ça y est même
envoyé des trucs dans la gueule c'est
quoi la prochaine étape le gâteau ballon
de rugby de foot que c'est que ça qui
sait que ça fait c'est que ça oui oh non
on va devoir se battre je suis prêt à
battre ah ben ça puisque remercier
d'animation spammant laquelle construire
sa mosquée meurt au mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça mais qu'est eliane mais
c'est pourquoi beaucoup à toi même et
des bas mais attends mais cette femme
est en train de mettre des baffes
delienne aux non [ __ ] pitié je suis
pas mort pitié ah non il faut plus que
des jeux pour tuer oui oh c'est l'heure
de rentrer dans cette salle je suis prêt
je prêt qu'est ce que c'est que cette
tombe là bas oh [ __ ] aller là où
regarder
à bas les plus là maintenant par la
porte c'est l'heure abba merci merci
c'est gentil et c'est j'allais justement
on te demande et ouvrir mais je n'avais
pas cet été l'humeur en fait ou alors ça
tous les coups ça va voler quelque part
non en animation
à cela il faut qu'ils se détournent
quand même un coup lui femmes du niveau
lâche pas rien alors comment ça se
termine
est-ce qu'elle saute bien sûr qu'elle
saute c'est le chat à l'ailé ouvert par
mais repart mais repasse heure de
questions tu peux t'en mais ne le mets
jamais vu un mec faire ça aussi
calmement quoi à ton maillot de se
poiler sur têt
ok ok et maintenant non à tout pour
garder le quand il va le remettre à
londres torche
non pourquoi je défie sont pour rien
alors et là boum
ah voilà avec ses cheveux voilà la
petite main ou là ou là a fait du piano
tu tu aide ou un piano je suis sûr qu on
se bat on va qu'est ce qu'on fait à mon
dieu mon démon démonter ou deux
questions très actuelles fait que tu vas
faire
ah oui non mais attends à d'accord avec
moi ah bah c'est mignon je pense qu'elle
se relève mais pas moi exactement comme
ça ah ok l'injustice total épisodes
terminés
elle émerge de la haine des victimes de
mort violente
on a fait l'usiné désaffectée hôpital
abandonné et là c'est les meubles
délabré c'est quoi le prochain épisode
la machine à laver cassé alors 3 300
fois les au bloc trois appartements 300
c'est ça holala pitié même la c3 ok
c'est celui-là là où logiquement ils
peuvent pas mieux nous indiquer que ça
ok s'appelle ken déjà parce que là je
sais que ça va mal se passer a les
cannes c'est l'heure de descendre des
marches de dire bonjour à l'arbre
bonjour à moi est assez en forme au nom
du droit ou à droite bas à droite là une
barrière luca donc oui il y avait un
truc qui brille regarder
je
ne jamais aller caste cadenas non mais
tu mets un chai pas moi à coup de pied
retourné de suite
ah bah non aux eaux [ __ ] que c'est que
ça à la haac et ça non c'est l'enfant
tout nu voilà je vous avais dit quoi il
a lancé abate nice matin il fasse
l'autruche plus sérieux 1
prends ça prend ça que ce qui bouge une
balançoire à bonjour juste un fond
invisible j'espère que tu as muse bien
moi pas du tout salué me dit comment ça
va un diamant je suis riche je me bats
en hélico d'ici à ses parts lacheroy
block3 bienvenus ici c'est le ghetto si
tu n'as pas l'a47 fait demi-tour
quelqu'un sonne chez quelqu'un de
manière répétée taille à l'autre qui
marche pieds nus encore quoi alors cette
animation blocs ou pas le truc là va
s'ouvrir voir des yeux 3,3 soit je suis
livreur d'accord alors tenant le mec
juste tu fais demi-tour quoi si tu vois
ça tu livres pas y'a pas moyen ok il a
sonné la partie verte
non mais attends mais le mec tient trop
à son métier quand ils sont emballés ce
n'est qu'il va y aller pour livrer moi
je vois ça je fais demi tour mais demain
alors la chute là je me suicide quoi sur
place c'est une pile qui a tenté de
faire chauffer une pile au micro-ondes
aux plats clé de cadenas je suis
quelqu'un avec des cadenas aux noms
entre de vêtements elle était cachée
pourquoi mon collier plein de sang à
temps mais c'est dans mon colis qu'elle
est oui mais ça n'a aucun sens mais
qu'elle se faisait que se coller quoi
o o terrière enquête mon estime on s'en
bat les steaks à l'étiage tendance mais
son état dans la capitale mais je compte
fait pas confiance se venge boulot puis
son spectacle dans des endroits gauche à
la gauche
oui on attend les mecs c'est bon non pas
du tout pas plus tard il faut qu'on se
parle à temps mais pourquoi il s'est pas
fermé en position foetale dans le pas
car ça c'était très bien
[ __ ] mais c'était un très bon plan
quoi way judas sommes plus conseil c'est
fini j'entends le bruit de la meuf un os
il y avait un mec a salué millibars on
s'est déjà vu est très homogène pour
dire bonjour j'ai pas le prendre mal
mais je suis excellent café une
plantation de braïla dans du sable
elle va zy le mec fait la balance [ __ ]
hockey a vu le bébé qui pleure mais ça
va combien de streamer à la seconde là
ça se sent pas du tout les gens il faut
aller là allez allez allez courage
courage courage a pas de raison qui est
un monstre à nouveau les chambres 202 go
boad des traces de sang demain sur le
mur un peu partout autour de moi
non non non je ne veux pas y aller je
n'ai pas un panneau qui claque ce rappel
ne comprends pas je t'ai vu petit objet
insolent
oh [ __ ] ya l'autre qui sonne quelque
chose qui sonne [ __ ] ils m'énervent
mnr ben oui j'arrive
j'arrive un peu de sang qui coule j'aime
ça ça y est j'ai déclenché le truc dont
j'ai un bug et où c'est vrai je suis
prêt musique
bush dès mon gars bah bill monga rabat
joie et coûte finalement il fait ce que
j'ai dis [ __ ] gauche n orias à moi
qu'à faire tac visiter comme ont vu dans
le cercle
oh là là mon gars je me crois aux tirs
pigeons je crois la fête foraine là il
fait quoi en fait je parle pas parce que
si je parle ça me fait trembler la
croissance du cerveau
est-ce que c'est enfin fini non salué me
dis salut emilienne salut émulation mon
coeur bonsoir sacs poubelles là serait
ce un sac poubelle remplie de farid et
ce ketchup oui c'est sûrement ça
tu ne me fait pas peur gbagbo au nom
vous avez entendu les eaux
ok c'est bon qu'est-ce qui se passe tu
ne fais pas peur
ok oh [ __ ] mais attendez quoi haute
route tout droit
celle où on est on y est au nom au nom
là la femme araignée
à l'aller on fait là on peut croire que
soit un titre avec cuisine pour battre
les hommes et pas du tout c'est un
tutoriel pour comment avoir peur à ces
mots je m'enfuis rats et on dégage un
dégagement dégagement dégage ça dégage
ça dégage et voilà [ __ ] ça dégage pas
du tout c'est ça c'est ça la fin c'est
fini ah j'ai entendu un bruit de choix
de cracotte votre épisode terminer et
voilà les gens c'est déjà fin de cette
deuxième vidéo sur the grudge en ont eu
tort oui si yes yes on se retrouvait
dans une nouvelle vidéo se sera pas de
l'aura faut laisser un petit entrepôt à
mon corps mes besoins qui était pension
à la suite de ce maudit jeu qu'à tout le
monde
pis c'est tout
[Musique]